Wizards of the Coast has recently
printed lots of cards that Exile your
opponent's cards and allow you to play
them and almost all of them have one
particular line of text you may spend
Mana as though were Mana of any color
this probably seems normal if you
started playing recently but it wasn't
always this way though many earlier
examples of library and hand ceiling
existed the first couple cards with that
particular line of text were printed in
Theos and as a black player the one I
remember well is psychic intrusion it
wasn't great even by 2013 standards but
it was nonetheless a bit of a curiosity
wow I guess they decided to cost this at
five Mana because of how flexible it is
you don't even need to be in your
opponent's colors to play their card it
was printed to a standard environment
where a common threat was night fail
Spectre which was a great utility beater
in devotion decks but a card where if
you weren't in your opponent's colors
you had to first play their lands and
then start casting their spells whenever
I come across KN fail Spectre nowadays I
get a bit of nostalgia but also a bit of
old man angst back in my day we actually
had to work to play our opponent's cards
you young wher Snappers would never
understand